all right so we're going to continue the
afternoon session
expert in information
about the role of incentives in
disclosing information
foreign
thank you very much it's been a great
pleasure to be here learn a lot from you
and so I'll give an overview of some of
my work in this area and so uh Laura
kindly came up with this title and so
then I will in a way talk about the
economics of statistics and what I'll do
I'll take some really simple basic
statistics model and I'll add a bit of
incentives
so so statistics is mostly based on
decision Theory and that are not
explicitly take into account uh
incentive problems as strategic Behavior
by the data provider or analyst
so what I'll do instead I will uh give
an overview of some very simple game
Purity models of data collection and
data reporting
and I will focus mostly on my work but
some work we've seen here clearly uh
very closely related to this
and in a sense uh as an economist I'm
also interested very much in uh
potentially the role for regulation you
know so
can we uh you know kind of design a
system uh change the rules of the game
in order to achieve a better outcome
uh now
the plan of the talk is as follows first
I will look at reporting of data which
is hard information in a way disclosure
and there I look I first talk about my
work on strategic sample selection where
I look at selective disclosure in hard
data reporting and then I will talk
instead about something more close to
persuasion where I look at a more
Dynamic setting where you have an
optional stopping problem data
collection results in Persuasion bias
so in the sense this is uh we link very
closely to hypothesis testing
and these more subsequential analysis
this is you know static and this is more
Dynamic setting and then if time permits
I will talk about some older work of
mine on uh reporting uh of soft
information so predictions where you
you've seen the data but you make a
prediction so it's not hard information
is instead information you can kind of
manipulate you know it's kind of cheap
talk models in a sense
um or and so and I will
talk about two classes of model one is a
forecasting contest models where uh
forecasters will have private
information about the state of the world
they compete for the best record yeah so
it's a bit like a contest and and then I
also talk about models instead where you
know forecaster wants to have developer
reputation to to have accurate
information so I call that reputational
forecasting or reputational cheap talk
so let's start with the first hard
information uh impact of sample
selection and this is mostly based I
give you the gist of the idea in this
paper published last year in econometric
with alfredo Italia my colleague at BO
Connie and Peter Norman Sorensen my
historical co-author and for my
classmate at the University of
Copenhagen and so
um bias researchers
um
um if they analyze observational data
they might um leave out some data they
don't lead to a conclusion they like
or they might choose a specification to
get the result that's significant or
result that they like or they might look
omit controls yeah so at the same time
even in experiment which is supposed to
be randomized we have a lot of evidence
that sometimes uh the randomization is
subverted
uh and you know if you give a treatment
to the healthiest rather than a random
patients then naturally you will see
more favorable outcomes
so outcomes are going to be more
favorable are going to be more likely at
the same time as an evaluator looks at
the data reported by this bias
researcher
um you know you will uh
raise the bar you'll be less convinced
by this favorable evidence so there are
these two effects yeah so uh will be
less convincing that treatment is
effective so you know one hand the data
is not being favorable but maybe is less
likely to be above the bar it's the
question here it's not so clear how this
sample selection affects in a way the
value of information yeah and so that's
the question and to be concrete here I
really look at the simplest possible
setting where you have you know the
paper looks at a way more General case
where you have a data set with n IID
draws but look at the case of what is
one data point I'm realistic but you
know it can be a standard it the system
all the work is understanding but the
main idea is there is a random data so
you're trying to learn about data
let's say the treatment effect you know
and you see X which is theta plus
Epsilon you know this is additive noise
where Epsilon is distributed according
distribution f look in this situation
this is a normal distribution
the distribution of noise
okay so and um
now again the paper contains the more
General case doesn't doesn't require
additive noise but the main idea is here
and you compare that to still one data
point but that data is selected it's the
maximum of K iodid draws
so you again uh is that recognized so
you have data plus Epsilon K where
Epsilon K is f to the power K because
the maximum of kiid draws
and so here I've done in the case that
for the normal distribution this is the
maximum of I think I do for maximum
three normals
you see here uh you know it's the
maximum two normal is a skew normal
distribution is skewed
you're more likely to see favorable
outcomes at the same time you see the
shape of distribution changes and the
shape is relevant for the information
value and let me explain how but before
I I found this nice quote by uh Colonel
who is a engineer French engineer some
of the father of uh Game Theory to some
extent with porno but also demand curve
is really pioneering he also worked on
wrote the book on probability
and I found this very nice quote in the
first half of the 19th century uh
statistical testing was very popular in
France yeah it was alamod and and uh and
so he was saying that what's happening
is the data gets manipulated and so that
really hinders credibility and so the
idea is that unsuccessful tests usually
leave no traces
and so then an evaluator is actually
unable to make any conclusion for data
report
so it drew to the conclusion that this
manipulation what we now call P hacking
notice 1843 it kind of creates a
credibility problem
let's see how it works out you know and
actually there's going to be a slightly
subtle answer I wouldn't be here
otherwise so
um there is um think about here I look
at the simplest possible setting though
uh the results is more General you can
either accept or reject
this hypothesis so the state cap is
binary either high or low so reject
display of R which is intermediate to
the payoff from acceptance which is
Theta H
um if the state is high and the platform
uh accepting this to this low is Theta L
which is lower than R so in the high
State you want to accept in the in the
low State you want to reject
so and so the actual result in the paper
works not only for hypothesis testing
problem for a very general class of
problems
um which is called internal dominance
order preferences of which single
Crossing is a special case or super
modular province is a special case and
currently Ruben Marathon decision
province is a special case so the result
is much more General yeah but in a sense
what I'm using here and this again
attribute to work done here at Berkeley
a very important result developed by
Eric lemon following up on the footstep
of uh David Blackwell
and I think he wrote you know David
Blackwell wrote a beautiful work in
1951-53 on characterizing uh the value
of information when you have
unrestricted domain all
the information structure is more
valuable than another if for any uh
utility function it gives you a higher
payoff while Layman looked at the
situation where you restrict the class
of decision problems in a natural way
which is natural for statistics and in
particular look at Caroline Rubin
Marathon decision problems
and so in in you know this uh works for
a class that is even larger than that
but it's natural you know by restricting
the class of decision problems you can
compare many more information structures
but it's natural to do so you know so uh
so that's the setting you know beyond
the example I give you but the intuition
is in the example and
um so go back to what we had location
experiment here and the standard case
the distribution IS F this is the random
data point yeah and so what what I will
assume is lock concavity of the density
which is equivalent given a location
structure to Mountain likely ratio
property I when you see a higher signal
uh you are more uh optimistic about the
state being high yeah so and with a
single draw you will basically have a
simple cutoff policy whereby if the
signal is above external level you will
accept
and if it's below you will reject and
graphically
and that's what you used
to see in statistics 101 so here on the
horizontal axis I have the signal X
and what I have the distribution here
for the random experiment the Baseline
yeah and given its location structure is
drawn for the case of a normal this
distribution is uh basically centered
around Theta l or Center of theta H is
like a translation you see and so and if
you uh have this bar of acceptance here
x bar and so whenever this signal is
above X bar you will accept you will
think the state is more likely to be
high you want to accept and so but if
the state is low here
condition on that you would have made a
mistake those are the false positives
acceptances they're positives but
they're false they're wrong you make a
wrong decision you should have rejected
because they saved this law
and similarly here if if it turns out
that you observe something below X bar
the state is high these are the fourth
negatives you reject because the
musician is low but you should have
accepted these are the two bad things
that are penalized in the payoff so this
is the Baseline uh with random
experiment let's look at a case with
select this pyramid in this yeah go
ahead let's talk when the density is
equal what was that about a big bar you
can actually find it like from this
formula here in the case of symmetry is
exactly uh you know that's it being
equal to full symmetry yes totally right
then you see in this example uh this
Loop here which is the density is equal
right because I look at this 100 what
generally is that form I gave you
that's right so uh now let's look at
what happens to select this paramet and
this is the trick this is lemon genius
okay so what I can do there is a policy
we select this paragraph that the I as
an evaluator who now sees the selected
data
point and I um I don't adopt X bar but I
can I can do this I can go up here
and I can guarantee the same post
positive rate
by you see uh raising the certain bar a
sentence bar to Y Bar yeah so at this
level here I just go up here
and down here on the red
which I've done that's the algebra for
the trick here so with that Y Bar there
look
the false positives are the same what's
happening to the false negatives
the first negative word here would be a
random experiment with the selected
experiment you see they are down here
which means I have the same false
positive rate but less false negatives
I.E I have a policy the guarantees as
much as I was doing before
actually better
and the optimal policy is going to be
even better
I.E I'm better off in this example with
a selected experiment once I adjust for
selection
key question is
your first negatives are reduced yes in
this example with normal you can see
graphically because what's the key
condition is the fact that after the
power K is less dispersed than f i e if
you look at this for any given
at quantile you look here you know so
the this slope is the density you see
you have a higher density in FK than you
have it in F for every quantity
so the the quantile difference in
decreasing thank you you have that
condition then you have the result
so the key key question is when is this
condition satisfied the normally
satisfied but for watch distribution and
this is the key result the gist of the
contribution of this paper and it's not
follow when is after the power case
deeper than F you know it requires a bit
more work because if you look at a
multi-dimensional sample you have the
highest uh you know like n or statistics
and you're comparing what happens as the
uh there is they're more and more
selected so you draw a sample
from a large and larger pre-sample
so what's the impact of that you know
the key theorem is this
is you fix the sample size here was one
example
and you rate you increase the pre-sample
size k
uh the the experiment becomes more
informative in every monotone problem uh
you know this ideal problems that give
you
I apologies testing it's a special case
if the reverse has a rate
the density over distribution function
is log super modular
so you take the ratio here you see
that's increasing yeah now
in the location uh case and now let me
see here in your when you go for
additive noise
this condition is equivalent to lock
concavity
of the reversal rate
and that's the example I gave in a
normal business status like what does it
mean lock concavity of the reverse has
already remember
more than likely ratio is locked
concavity of the density
local Capital density implies lock on
Capital distribution function by
pre-copus theorem
so they're both were concave
what I'm saying is the key condition is
that density is more like concurred in
distribution function
kind of a strengthening of multiple
accuration property
a little more satisfies that but there
is a case where selection is neutral
you know and it is the key where these
reversals a rate is
log linear
the density is equally lock concave
compared to the distribution function
and there is the situation which in
selection is harmful even if you
properly adjust for it
which is the lock convex case
for example the exponential distribution
okay so let me give you why so the
goombal distribute of the gamble sorry
in the US I think you say Gamba here
um but um
what you have here is the gumball here
and this is the gumball F to the power K
so it's an extreme value distribution
and so what you have is the maximum of
uh two uh gun that is also Gamble
you just shift it by log k
but the shape doesn't change
so the First Quality for negative rates
are identical
so it's selection neutral once you're
just for selection there's no impact
okay that's a neutral case the boundary
and uh so the exponential noise here you
f f k you see here is the opposite of
what we see in the normal case so
selection
increases dispersion so it reducing
information about intuitively with
selection you're pushing stuff in the
tail it's already relatively take tail
and then it's more difficult to make
inference okay now and instead in the
kind of regular normal case uh you know
selection is actually increase you know
pushing stuff in detail but not so much
so it allows you to actually make better
inference and if you think about it as
K goes to Infinity
it becomes like a constant here
at Infinity if you properly adjust with
still a goombal distribution but with
the variance of zero
yeah link to a string value theory yes
go ahead why are we comparing uh
no selection with selection rather than
averaging various selection because okay
it seems to me that the honest thing
could have been if we are not biased
researchers is that we have these key
things into the bags we could have
average correct you know maybe I'm not
sure fully uh let me let me try and
answer but let me have more so um
now notice here I'm holding fix the
sample size
which is n equal to one here or whatever
n is and I'm increasing the standard of
selection the the pre-sample size yeah
but I'm holding fixed the sample size
but clearly if you
um you know uh if you can see all the
data the more data is more informed in
the sense of like we know that right
does it answer a bit Yeah Yeah
but uh so here you know the paper
clearly goes in its place but in a way
um actually what we also show in some
situations when the uh researcher has to
pay cost to acquire more data it
actually might be optimal to commit to
limit the sample size
and you know you live with some uh you
know kind of bias coming from the fact
of the researcher as an incentive
modeling Center for information and you
might want to limit the sample size
so the data goes and extends this basic
framework to just justify here the way I
think about it and let me step back a
second you know is the researcher here
has key data lines
available and he is told just recording
about him saying whole fix and let's
increase the free sample size when K is
equal to Y and there is no selection
and increasing selection I'm saying
monotonically increases or decreases
the value information for in a in the
future always clearly there are
distributions that don't satisfy either
of these two conditions and then it kind
of depends and I can also baptize that
there are many other cases and just the
focus of the most settlement to explain
it so that's the exercise but the idea
is that the researcher is biased so if
you don't tell him a calorie structure
of him or her report that hand I and
Report the end we reported him highest
because he wants acceptance in in the
background I have an idea that the
research is biased over the sentence
report the highest and I'm asking
because of that will will that
completely undermine credibility means
no do you know the center selection you
can actually have
foreign
you don't know the cost of applying
information and that hinders
inference that's an effect that goes
negative and you can think about this is
just a baseline let's say the first
intuition that selection uh is is bad no
actually lower the selection is good
percent
but basically the name simple takeaway
thank you okay so now uh went over this
idea that what is this test in selected
data and what I concluded is selection
benefits Parts is data as a thinner
or thicker in that case it tail than
Goomba what really matters is the top
tail if you think about limit selection
you know and so that's the main idea we
you know in a sense you take the Google
distribution
and if you one sweat convex transform
order if you have a convex
transformation you have a ticker tailed
and Gumball
in the convex transform order then
selection is harmful but if it's a
concave transformation like the normal
of the gumball distribution then
selection is beneficial and that's the
one
second thing I want to do is talk about
and I know I'm stretching with the
second model here but you're very
familiar with wall sequential and now
it's 1947 work that he did during the
war
um then um and I'm asking that contest
is
um what if rather than being a
statistician collecting information you
have an agent collecting information
sequentially because an optional
stopping problem in a sense that and uh
and the kind of model here is based on
work with MRI concrete a science book
and published an economic review in 2019
so the Informer here is our you know the
often called sender uh researcher is
benefits from approval let's say of a
drug with uncertain efficacy so the
state can be high or low like before
yeah and so the evaluator uh is let's
say the FDA or you know doctors deciding
whether to adopt or not a drag uh want
to have adopt a drug if it is effective
but not if if it's not or if it's unsafe
yeah
and um
the informers the Pharma company
banished from approval
I you don't need that is exactly the you
know kind of uh biased with that state
which is perfect does not depend on the
state but what's key it's biased over
toward uh toward approval so this is
just a simple illustration and so the
Informer here sequentially acquires
information and information is uh
becomes uh can be reported but it cannot
be manipulated
and diffuses this in constant
information but the information is cost
to acquire at the cost see it every
instant and this information comes in
continuous time in each instance decide
should I acquire one more signal one
more trial and then the patient with the
poorly or well and it's more likely the
patient does well if the state is high
the drug is a
so in each instant you decide should I
acquire more or should I stop as an
agent
and then you can go to the evaluator
show your data and evaluate your decide
should I adopt or not so you can
basically embed this framework into a
game and I just go very quickly now but
the key is the evaluator as potentially
course instruments for regulation maybe
you can decide whether to prove or
reject maybe ask for additional evidence
maybe impose liability and whereby
affect this payoff
that's where the economist comes into
some extent so uh so there are two
players here
and so there's the Informer who directly
controls the information by paying the
cost
of acquiring information and always once
approved on this simple setting is
biased over approval
but does not value directly information
because here is a payoff which is taking
dependent but instrumentally cares about
information very much like in the
persuasion model you know you can think
about it's very closely to that
evaluator directly controls approval
decision with a certain payoff but as no
direct access to information it just
relies on Informer
providing it okay now
world classic Benchmark in a sense
conflates you know these two individuals
into one is that kind of social Planet
problem
who's uh controls all the decision
rejection approval and information
acquisition and also obtains a total
payoff the sum of the payoff of Informer
and evaluator
yeah
so and pays the information cost
that's the setting in a sense I'm
basically deconstructing
uh world into splitting the path between
two players and so classic world is a
picture you've seen uh you know uh many
times so here is
um the belief in the state is a binary
State the probability the Theta is high
here there is maybe Q hat I should have
called it this thing the myopic cutoff
without experiments you will uh you know
uh take the drug if it is above that my
Africa tough and Below you will reject
but now because you have access to this
information as a social plan and think
about the world problem you have an
access policy whereby if it's
intermediate the belief you will keep
acquiring information and in continuous
time and the belief will keep moving
around until it is
added this boundary or this boundary and
then you will stop there and then you
can compute uh the the value function
actually using some classic formula
which we we leverage a lot uh you can
have a nice uh characterization of this
yeah now that's the world uh problem and
now what I've done here you can think
about actually uh the problem is nice
nicely you can Pro concavity and so on
so you can choose this standard of
approval capital S as a function given
the standard of rejection lowercase s
it's like a first order condition there
and similarly you can choose this one
given that and the the crossing of these
two first of the condition characterizes
the the solution
and now the uh you know the social
planner wall That's why W here see you
solve those two
and you find the solution
what I'm what I do instead here I have a
player I the Informer and evaluator they
solve kind constrained world problems I
mean basically I make assumption on how
they interact in a dynamic game and I
give you roughly the the bottom line
here uh so we split payoffs additional
rights and so I compare different
extensive forms of this what I call
World persuasion games
or different organizations one is
informal Authority where in a sense
these Informer
um
chooses uh when to uh stop acquiring
information lowercase s
given in a sentence uh standard capital
S which is which the informal respects
the evaluator to uh to have capital S
and capital S the valuator will approve
whenever is above the myopic cutoff
so in a situation here the information
is all the power in a way and so we'll
give no rent to the uh to the evaluator
it will basically stop acquiring
information exactly myopic cutoff for
the evaluator and uh if the information
were costly it will always acquire
information in a way go all the way to
zero right but this information is
costly will stop short
yeah at some point we need sufficiently
pessimistic is not worth keeping the
cost because it's unlikely to hit the
boundary that allows you to persuade the
evaluator to adopt
okay that's one potential scenario
another scenario where you know none of
them can commit to some extent and then
you know each one chooses the uh the um
information when to uh withdraw approve
uh collection of data and evaluator
chooses when to uh to adopt
and so it's a bit like this situation
here but they have they do this um first
order condition or this best replies to
become uh for given that payoff the
Informer and the evaluator
yeah so which I characterized that I'll
show you shortly and then there is a
potentially another solution which is by
natural
is the uh which is a stackable solution
yeah the evaluator chooses the uh
acceptance standard capital s
take into account that the Informer will
best reply to that maximizing
his own informants payoff
so just to give you a you know a gist
and I like graphs as you might have seen
here uh so what I have here the way to
think about it is I have on the axis
here I have both the belief between 0 1
as well as the um rejection standard
lowercase s and here is also the belief
but also the acceptance standard Capital
case s
yeah and the way to read this is uh is
the kind of the best reply
space you know and in particular here
I'm looking at informers best best reply
here which is lowercase s which is put
on the horizontal axis given the capital
case as chosen in a way by the evaluator
given and intuitively if the evaluator
is more choosy you know it kind of uh it
really approves when it's pretty
confident to avoid false positives it
once a really high standard of approval
then intuitively the Informer will uh
will give up
oh yeah
so if you just uh if the at the stream
if the evaluator requires to be 100 sure
you're never going to be 100 sure I give
up
so lowercase s will be one you see so
that's the increasing function yeah so
this best reply you can prove is
increasing and because of loss of
control you don't control when it's
approved you're discouraged if the buy
is very high
now and in the informal Authority game
the Informer the an informers the
authority and so the
um evaluator will um very much you know
in the spirit of coming it's against
genskow uh the um
the evaluator will will approve whenever
you're above the myopic us off
and so at the end the uh the equilibrium
will be like this and so this would be
the region of learning the capital case
s will be at a myopic cutoff for the
evaluator and the best reply to that
will be the lowercase s
and you see here in a sense
um the informant stops as soon as
evaluator is persuaded and the informal
withdraws when is pessimistic enough
and so we can compare to community
commitment solution and what you see
when the cost goes to zero and also
discount factor which the model also
allows for discounting for other
generality they both go to zero uh then
you actually recover companies against
genscaus commitment solution
yeah and uh so here is the value
function we've seen this morning correct
this is the uh coming here coming
uh payoff here so if I just add
um discounting here this is the
concatified part this become complex I
convexifying a bit and with the cost but
still I give up at zero because you know
I the information is costly it's just
discounted but if it's also costly I
give up a short of of being a zero you
see but again you know see the the
structure is very much like what they
have either you have a binary outcome
either you know persuaded evaluate is
persuaded or
uh you know the informant will give up
so uh in a sense this shows that the
commitment assumption often uh
people criticize uh coming to Jen Scout
for uh the essential commitment here
it's just worse also without commitment
to some extent yeah and also you can
think about more generally the structure
will be similar for kind of any uh you
know way in which these two players
interact would have a similar structure
and so for example the Nash outcome of
no commitment solution the evaluator
gains commitment power uh for example
there you are looking at a stationary
microperative equilibrium where at the
end uh the Informer controls the
withdrawal standard which is a best
reply for informal payoff to the capital
case as chosen by the uh by the
evaluator which is chosen as best reply
to lowercase app so in a way we have the
best reply for the Informer in red and
so
um this is the best reply for the uh
evaluator here and the crossing here and
again you can see there's a tangency
that like you're familiar with Chrono or
stacker back and now it's a very similar
intuition and construction so uh so this
is a locus of tangency points and so you
will have these will be the uh the Nash
equilibrium here's the original learning
okay so intuitively now the evaluator
will uh potentially uh get some positive
payoff you know
get appropriate some of the information
right here
and uh but the uh there would be less
false positives but they're going to be
uh more Force negatives because the uh
informal is discouraged but a higher bar
the results in equilibrium
and so
um developers that's more stringent
approval standard and you can ask
yourself what if the evaluator were able
to commit to set the standard in advance
in order to influence the information
acquisition uh by the Informer where
would you set that at a higher lower
level compared to no commitment
and you can already see here intuitively
is that you know this is already this
vertical tangency here you will want to
commit here to be somewhere like here
so you want to actually be more lenient
in order to encourage more information
application you're willing to live with
more false positives because uh you know
to actually uh reduce false negatives
and it's always optimal
yeah so that's basically this and this
is the commitment path you know as a
functional initial belief here
which spans the Informer and the Nash
equilibrium
so
um
yes but uh I roughly gave a bit of a
gist here but it's a good way to stop
and answer questions yes
that
um
uh the FCA who commit to something that
looks nice and stationary and also but
no it's not at all
um Andrew McLendon University of Chicago
is job market paper shows that you know
the policies they you know you can do
better
uh uh you know it's a very very mistake
yeah and so yeah
that's you know it's a no stationary uh
commitment that is very nice without us
great question
yes uh so
um
okay so just to summarize the economics
equilibrium persuasion there's a biased
from optional stopping
at the same time you want to tolerate
false positive to encourage uh
information collection and reduce false
negatives and often we forget about that
yeah the fact that if we are very tough
then uh there will be less information
collection and so and so we we really
pay the price with more false uh
negatives okay so how am I doing with
time I'm happy to answer more questions
because you know this is a bit uh I
thought I would stop here but I'm happy
to go and say a bit more uh
going back in history all the all the
contributions go ahead yes what was in
the problem searching of the second
problem that kind of like stops us from
doing tea hacking like uh yes I mean in
a sense
here
there is some sort of P hacking which
again in equilibrium is anticipated
if you were to add additional level
uncertainty not a little bit like in the
other model would be fully anticipated
but uh there is something happening here
in a sense because there is speculation
bias even in the Baseline
yes so basically persuasion
you should translate into this context
also here we don't care if the outcome
of the test like doesn't satisfy a
functions yeah I mean it's you know what
in equilibrium the evaluators like I'm
enough but in a former uh Authority you
will get no value information because
all the benefit will be appropriate by
the farmer company once you introduce
regulation then uh you know with more
commitment power you see there will give
me some value and so that's that's the
way
so that will reduce
by the way I also had
that I post but I thought this more
theoretical audience I focus on more on
the basic ideas uh more competitive as
well but then uh what depending on the
questions here how much
these are a few slides here I can
depends on your patients and other
questions here
let me see pose again
okay
I am becoming tougher and tougher you
see more and more models I must say go
ahead yes
uh okay so let me try it okay honest
forecasting is uh now we're talking
about reporting predictions rather than
data and so this is the Baseline I start
only from a statistical Baseline the
classic Model of forecasting you
minimize the mean square error with the
forecast and you're reporting the
expectation
yeah which has a nice orthogonality
properties they've been tested
extensively and the forecasts are
dispersed by less than the state
now this is the Baseline and uh for the
sake of uh concreteness Focus maybe the
the prior is normal maybe the signal is
normal and everything this would be
normal and so on you know just to fix
ideas
now uh
you're probably familiar with the wisdom
of the crowds in particular with the
Francis galton's uh uh you know actually
came up with the distribution functions
also one of my heroes Heroes you know
like the cousin of Charles Darwin
um and he uh was he was in the mid 80s
when he went to this uh aux weight
competition in Plymouth and he saw this
peasants uh you know submitting uh uh
kind of uh guesses for the weight of
this ox and then he collected all this
data and he published in one of the
first issue of nature uh this
distribution of the end is like the
average gas was spot on was just a few
pounds away from the correct weight as
you all know the story now what is the
game here you know as a you know and uh
with large number of forecasters in my
set in many guessers
each observes a singer IID
about the state which is the weight
and forecasters simultaneous and meter
forecast
M am I that's the game and then the true
state is publicly observed and and then
whoever is closest wins if there is a
continuous very large number you know
they're going to be somebody's gonna
stop like close enough they've been on
top and they will win
okay so that's the game and think about
this is a normal prior here an
observicing here and so the posterior is
going to be somewhere in between the
posterior expectation between the prior
and the signal I see here Okay so
so what should I do here should I report
my honest guess
or not
okay
I don't think Carlton fully asked a
question but I did
I didn't know about Gato when I wrote
this paper honestly but uh I learned a
few a few weeks after I published the
paper and I wish I knew I would have put
it in you know in the paper but I didn't
know that
[Music]
um
but actually I should have known because
uh
Garten was rediscovered uh by suryaki
and the book was published in 2005 a
year before I published but by the time
maybe the page was accepted I just
probably discovered very quickly but it
was too late
I probably didn't fully see the
connection uh so now what's going on
here
if you are truthful if you are reporting
your posterior expectation
so when you think the weight is is just
there given it prior giving a signal you
think it's here that's what's most
likely gonna be right
looks like a good thing to do
but you have to ask yourself where are
the other guys what is my competition
you know because there is a chance in
the limit with a large number of
forecasters go to continue forecaster
that you are there are you have to share
the price with the others
so in a way what you can show
so there is a and if you move away from
this
away from the prior in this direction
then you have again there's a second
order
last year because it's flat you reduced
a bit the probability of being spot on
but when you win you're you're splitting
with less people
and I characterize in normal case the
symmetric pure strategic equilibrium the
results in a very nice close form
okay so actually in operations research
people also push this agenda and
generalize this result it can be pushed
further and at the end what you have so
this is the density uh
of forecast you uh and this is the the
density procedure so what you have is
the equilibrium forecasts are more
valuable than the posterior petition
let's think intuitively about maybe the
limit case suppose that I have no
information my signal is uninformative
so I mean all the forecasters they all
have an informative signal but they have
the same prior there is you know does it
probably would be normal not one of
these because it's not the cryo here
it's a nice normal suppose we are all
truthful so we have a signal which is
just noise we should report a prior mean
but we all reported prior mean we are
all share the price we want to be
different so there is no pure strategy
equilibrium in that case you see that
now what's happening is that with the
signal you have you purify the
equilibrium and so the way you you just
differentiate by actually putting a bit
more weight on your Sigma that's the
intuition so this is a version of
hoteling location game again gray
statistician who did important
contribution also to Game Theory and
this is a version of a tally location
game where the players have um if noise
information about the state where the
consumer is or you know in that model or
the politician the preference of the
voters
so you can think about the standing of
telling location theory to allow for
private information about the state okay
that's just a nice example of that but
then uh these are really stretching I
should stop and because the other model
uh I let you uh check it out it goes in
the opposite direction the replication
shipstop model let me just summarize
concern for accuracy which I show in
these other chip talk model lead
um through a sexy Conformity if the
market is naive and lots of information
in the market is rational that's the
other model you present instead
completion for best accuracy record
leads to excessive differentiation under
a bunch of assumptions in a way let me
just a bit self-critical here as
economists we like to be provocative we
like to pick special keys where I can
say a lot of things over specifying the
model and that's a very good example I
mean I I cook up the model to get the
results I want but I think uh you know
it's fun we can learn something and then
we can try to think be more honest try
to be more General and try to think
about what's really important but there
is a bit of that you know in this second
part especially actually to just that
have simple models you can solve and you
can learn you can insight and to me one
of the big advantages of theory is that
we can relate better to data we have a
framework to understand the word better
but also we can get some insights yeah
so there are the two two benefits of
theory and so let me just stop here so
it was been great to
attend this
okay
I don't have time for one question one
of Malibu sets up
foreign
social s
now the pure surgery breaks down
all right okay thank you thank you